-Higgins, want to explain
how this works?
Higgins, come on.
[ Light laughter ]
Come on.
-You'll choose a category.
-Okay.
-Right?
Then you'll take turns
naming things in that category.
Gotcha.
-Okay, whosever clock
runs out first, loses the round.
-Okay.
-And if you think
your opponent said something
that doesn't fit that category,
you can hit
the challenge button.
[ Horn blares ]
-And call their bluff.
And you call their bluff.
Yep, and the judges say
yes or no.
-Okay.
-We're gonna take a look
at the categories.
They are...
Superheroes.
-Oof.
-Herbs and spices.
-"Erbs," I think.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-"Rarck" bands.
-Rock bands.
-French "wards."
-French words.
-"Animils" with tails.
-Animals with tails.
-And 16th century
Swedish architects.
[ Laughter ]
Margot, why don't you pick
the first category?
-I would have to go with
the thing I know most about
and say 16th-century
Swedish architects.
[ Laughter ]
-All right, these --
Any Swedish architect
from the 16th century.
20 seconds on the clock.
Margot, hit your button
when you're ready.
And go.
-[ Laughs ]
-Uh...
Hugen Flu Flugen.
[ Laughter ]
-Challenging that.
[ Horn blares ]
-Judges?
[ Buzzer ]
Oh! You got it wrong.
Margot gets that round.
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Jimmy, your turn.
-Wait.
-Pick a category.
-All right,
we start back from 20, right?
-Yep, start back from 20.
Reset the clock.
-All right, my category.
I'm gonna go with herbs --
herbs and -- herbs and spices.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
This is any herb or spice,
according to herbwisdom.com.
So don't get nuts.
If it's not on Herb Wisdom,
you don't get the points.
-Sounds like a reliable source,
okay.
-Sounds like a weed thing.
[ Laughter ]
-Dr. Weed, yeah.
I get all my herbs from there.
-All right, so, who goes first?
-You start, you start. Ready?
-All right,
so I press it, right?
-Yep.
-There you go.
Rosemary.
-Oregano.
-Uh, uh, uh --
She said oregano.
Sorry, I'm gonna say --
Sorry, chives.
-Chives.
-Um, um, parsley.
-Italian parsley.
-Italian parsley. Ooh!
-Cumin.
-I'm gonna say, uh, uh...
Oh, my gosh.
Red -- Red pepper.
-Red pepper!
-Turmeric.
-Pepper.
-Salt.
-Uh...
Mrs. Lawry's seasoning salt.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh-ho-ho!
Are you gonna hit the challenge?
-Paprika.
-Oh!
[ Buzzer ]
Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thanks.
-Wow!
-I thought
I was gonna win that one.
-Jimmy, I'm on form tonight.
-Oh, my gosh.
-You're ready to go.
-You're spicy.
[ Air horn ]
Oh! You know what that
sound means, don't you?
-We go to Jersey Shore?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, it means...
it's time for the final round.
-Are we in a club?
-You're in a club
for the final round.
-Okay.
-And this round, I'm gonna say,
is worth 50,000 points.
[ Laughter ]
-I thought
you were gonna say dollars.
I was like, "Whoa!"
[ Laughter ]
-All right, ready?
I'm going to pick the category.
-Okay.
-Gonna reset this clock.
And you know what?
I'm gonna choose rock bands.
-Okay.
-Any band...
that knows how to rock.
-Mm.
-All right, Margot,
you're gonna start us off.
-Aerosmith.
-Guns N' Roses.
-KISS.
-The Doors.
-Slipknot.
-Beatles.
-Metallica.
-Rolling Stones.
-[ Laughs ]
Did I say Aerosmith already?
-I don't know.
-We don't know.
[ Laughter ]
-Beach Boys?
-Oh.
Uh...AC/DC.
-Oh!
I should've had that one.
Metallica? No!
-Oh!
-Dang it!
[ Horn ]
-Judges?
-Did I?
Did I already say Metallica?
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
That's a barn burner!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, no.
No!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Air horn blares ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughing ]
Margot Robbie!
[ Cheers and applause ]